when I met a famous monk in New York
City I was with Jay Shetty for the first
couple of years of my life I was dealing
with this kind of mental conundrum as to
whether committing my life to building
businesses which would ultimately enrich
myself was that a worthier cause than me
going back to the village in Africa and
saving just one life with the skills
that I have right like what was more of
a worthy Pursuit so when I was in New
York and Jay introduced me to this Monk
and there's this big room of people I
got to ask one question so I asked that
question I said like if I could go to
Africa and I was like 22 23 I was young
I could go to Africa and like commit my
time to saving one life or I could carry
on building these businesses which one
is more worthy which one should I be
doing and the monk said to me you cannot
pour out for others that in which you do
not have yourself